[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans dimanche
en politique votre émission de à débat
en franche-comté 6 mai 1968 6 mai 2018
il ya 50 ans tout juste débuté ce qu'on
a appelé les événements de mai 68 une
mobilisation d'abord étudiante puis
ouvrière qui a débouché sur une crise
politique majeure
alors un demi siècle plus tard que
faut-il retenir que reste t-il de mai 68
on va en débattre avec nos trois invités
je vous les présente tout de suite
d'abord jean cadets vous étiez délégué
cgt à peugeot sochaux la plus grande
usine automobile de france en mai 1968
également sur ce plateau une autre
salarié de peugeot à l'époque monique
rousseau vous vous avez travaillé en mai
1968 tout simplement parce que vous
étiez gaulliste vous avez été par la
suite député rpr du pays de montbéliard
et puis sur ce plateau également florian
pasqualini
aujourd'hui vous travaillé dans la
communication à besançon mais vous êtes
aussi l'auteur d'un mémoire
universitaire sur les événements de mai
68 dans le monde de l'industrie du pays
de montbéliard bonjour à tous les trois
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
notamment pour partager vos souvenirs de
68 et nous donner votre point de vue sur
l'héritage de cette période
alors comme d'habitude vous pouvez vous
aussi devant votre télévision participer
à cette émission et l'a commentée sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le mot diez qui
s'affiche dit mme paul fc comme dimanche
en politique franche comté madame
messieurs depuis le début de la semaine
ont donc débuté les célébrations
d'anniversaires de mai 68 50 ans après
jean cadets que faut-il retenir que
faut-il fêter selon vous de cette
période bien ce que l'on fait c'est je
crois déjà que cette grève a été une des
grèves est plus importante
un du xxème siècle que la grève a été
longue elle a connu des moments heureux
des moments dramatiques l'on joint on en
reparlera
et heureusement c'est du rêve a été un
succès les salariés ont obtenu une
augmentation de salaire depuis 14 % pour
les ouvriers
une engagement de réduction du temps de
travail parce qu'il faut savoir qu'à
l'époque lors elle était de 46 5 heures
par semaine 9h15 par jour et en
considérant que ce qu'avaient les
conditions très pénibles ios pour
certains venaient vrillé spécialisés
voilà les ouvriers spécialisés qui
travaillent sur les chaînes comme l'on
dit on aujourd'hui on parle de lignes de
montage mais les chaînes sais plus je
pense
parlant on est assujettie à la chaîne
certains venaient de très loin de plus
50 km ce qu'ils aient que ceux qui
commençaient à 4 heures du matin parfois
se lever à 2 heures du matin
transportés en car finissez à 13h 15h
par fait chez eux est rentré à 3 heures
de l'après midi c'est à dire des
journées très longues avait décrit un
travail très difficile donc ce que vous
retenez vous ce sont finalement les
acquis sociaux notamment sur les
conditions de travail les conditions de
travail déjà en 80 il y avait déjà eu
des grès pour faire en sorte que les
conditions de travail s'améliorent
j'avais un début
d'applications en 85 là une grande grève
avait lieu pour le droit sciences des
salaires qui s'est fait que soldée par
un échec malheureusement avec des
licenciements délai parler de 61 et 65
vous avez ainsi les dates on peut sans
brouiller un peu effectivement 65 pardon
et en 67 et il y avait eu aussi des
mouvements contre les ordonnances de qui
mettait en cause la sécurité sociale
donc c'est que 68 en fait des pannes et
de nulle part
68 c'est une continuation des luttes qui
étaient très nombreux à sochaux depuis
de très nombreuses années
dire que mai 68 n'est pas dans un ciel
sans nuage
différentes manifestations qui ont lieu
au cours des années 60 qui seules
souvent par des défaites ouvrière et
donc 68 et un peu l'aboutissement de
tous ces mouvements qui sont succédé et
puis il ya un mouvement avant 68 il ya
un mouvement un peu emblématique ici en
franche comté c'est la rodia c'est à
besançon 60 à l'avs tout africain 1967
lévriers 67 effectivement une grande
grève à la rodia c'est un championnat
sur un ticket qui s'est soldée
malheureusement ensuite par la fermeture
de l'usiné est en effet très attentifs
bien évidemment à ce qu'il soit fait à
leur exercice à monique rousseau vous
qui ne faisait pas partie des grévistes
en 68 que retenez-vous de cette période
eh bien je dois vous dire que ce que
j'en retiens le plus c'est la violence
avec laquelle ont été traités par des
collègues en fait les gens qui voulaient
travailler
c'était très tendu entre les grévistes
et oui ça et moi je l' ai vécu de
l'intérieur
mais je dirais d'un intérieur un peu
externalisée puisque j'ai mes bureaux
étaient à ce qu'on appelait
lusine des pièces détachées et c'était
ses pièces détachées à l'entrée de
montbéliard c'était sur montbéliard et
pas sur sochaux mais c'est l'unité qui a
déménagé après avoir ces soldes c'est
cela oui donc c'était on suivait les
manifestations par exemple moi je me
souviens d'une fois j'étais j'étais
jeune à l'époque et il y avait un défilé
des grévistes donc qui passait pour
aller à la sous préfecture ou à la
mairie devant les bureaux devant le
bâtiment où étaient mes gros je vai avec
deux collègues la fenêtre pour regarder
passer les grévistes et je me souviens
que notre patron qui était le maire de
valentigney le ciel l'air et qui nous
dit écoutait les gamines
ou bien vous allez avec eux ou bien de
vos bureaux
c'était pas un spectacle quoi et
pourquoi et pourquoi vous n'allez pas
avec eux qu'est ce qui motive votre
choix de travailler à l'époque mais
parce que je suis fière et heureuse
d'être chez peugeot depuis 1958 d'avoir
d'être entré dans cette entreprise qui
fait vivre tout le pays et avec
l'intention de d'essayer de me faire une
situation donc de gravir des échelons
mais je suis fier heureuse d'être dans
ses cuisines et je ne vois pas pourquoi
je ferai grève
je n'ai aucune raison permettez je vais
sera un peu en faut parfois ce que dit
madame rousseau
la grève s'est déclenchée le 20 je le 20
mai 25 20 mai le loonie va mais à 16
heures du matin le secrétaire du ce et
rené chez au monde sur sa voiture dans
la cour du building appellent à la grève
la grève est décidé l'usiné est occupée
tout le personnel est évacué le levée
des piquets de grève se mettre en place
yao eu aucune violence personne ne s'est
opposé à ce moment là et après la
violence d'où elle est venue on en
reparlera peut-être la violence elle est
venue du côté des forces de l'ordre crs
qui malheureusement le 11 juin ont tué
en de nos collègues pierre beylot d'une
balle de 9 mm ou violent il ya eu deux
décès
une peugeot de sochaux sur les cinq
morts officiels sur l'ensemble de la
verrerie bhl et henri blanche et le
deuxième la deuxième personne qui est
décédée était un spectateur au dessus du
seuil rails et il est tombé mais je
crois que c'est à l'arrière et sur 1 sur
une mêlée déflagration d'une grenade qui
va déstabiliser mais on vient par
secteur on nettoie les lits n'a pas les
preuves du pour le pour la seconde
personne qui est décédée on a du mal à
trouver même dans les rapports de police
de l'époque et c'est ce qui s'est
véritablement passé il n'y a pas
beaucoup de témoins ne sait pas vraiment
si c'est le sauve d'une grenade
offensive ou s'il aurait glissé et s'il
serait tombé évidemment il était
effectivement ce réalisateur est tombé
sur une radio où il se serait fracassé
le crâne les violences raison et lui
aussi se réjouit il ya eu plus de 150
blessés dont deux ont eu les pierres h
et on va voir les images effectivement
des affrontements à peugeot-sochaux au
mois de juin mais c'est très violent
effectivement monsieur pasqualini ce qui
marque aussi c'est la différence entre
le début de la grève le début de la
mobilisation étudiante tout premiers
jours de mai et finalement le temps que
mettent les syndicats a embrayé
notamment dans les usines comment on
explique ce délai de deux supérieurs à 2
3 semaines
alors en fait ce qui est paradoxal on
pense que le mouvement commence plus
tard à sochaux mais en fait c'est pas
vrai il commence à peu près au même
moment que les autres ouvriers du raid
et de la france le mouvement étudiant
commence le 6 mai le mouvement à sochaux
et dans la plupart des lignes de france
démarre entre le 18 et le 22 mai donc à
sochaux c'est le vin ce qui explique il
ya différentes
on est loin de paris on est loin du
mouvement étudiant et puis dans le pays
de montbéliard on a plus peut-être de
mal à rentrer dans les moments on a
aussi plus de mal à les terminer
donc ça c'est une vraie miss en fait si
la grève a commencé le lundi va mais on
peut dire que les prix soient été le
très vif et station le trail a en ce
moment où la crise les râles a été
décidée par un autre confédération en a
vu il ya quelques instants d'ailleurs
des images des manifestations de
l'époque dans les principales villes
la région il ya notamment des images
devant la préfecture de besançon où il
ya un monde fou oui c'est dingue pour
l'époque le l'un des 13 b donc il y
avait la paix la grève générale est
toujours à l'écouté
l'entreprise prétextant demande
d'électricité et a voulu nous faire
récupérer ce jour là le samedi 18 mai et
le 18 mai on s'est opposé à la
récupération est ce qui a entraîné comme
on décide la grève le lundi va mais
voilà mais effectivement il y avait
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes soient besançon ou dans le
pays de montbéliard il faut savoir que
dans le pays de montbéliard à l'époque
c'est 70% de la population active qui
travaillent dans l'industrie ce qui est
énorme parce que pour le reste de la
france la moyenne à peu près de 36%
c'est pour un peu mesuré le poids que
j'aurais à boire on à la région la plus
industrielle de france mais qu'est la
franche comté avec la bourgogne franche
comté c'est à peine différent mais la
franche comté était sûre quand il y
avait une vingtaine de régions c'était
la région la plus industrielle de france
monique rousseau quand on est gaulliste
et qu'on voit ses collègues
faire grève comment comment on réagit
comme envie les événements parce que
derrière la grève et les revendications
sociales il ya aussi une remise en cause
du général de gaulle et ça c'est quelque
chose que je n'ai jamais su ce que je ne
supporte pas à l'époque que je n'ai
jamais supporté de ma vie donc c'est pas
maintenant que j'ai commencé mais
simplement je dis moi j'avais peut-être
ça a été une chance un privilège j'en
sais rien je ne suis entré à l'intérieur
de lusine qu'au départ des pièces
détachées pour vesoul
donc j'avais commencé ma carrière chez
peugeot ce qui s'appelait à l'époque le
centre de livraison ou les
concessionnaires venaient de toute la
france cherchait des voitures pour leurs
clients
ensuite pour ben j'avais l'intention
quand même d'essayer de faire une
carrière
donc je suis allé à la rs qui était à
côté de ce centre livraison mais
toujours avec à l'extérieur de l'usiné
où j'ai tenu la caisse des départs à
sion et tout pendant six ans un petit
nombre d'années et puis ensuite je suis
parti donc aux pièces pièces détachées
avant qu'elle ne parte à vesoul
donc je n'étais pas dans l' usine mais
j'avais des informations du sinn par mon
mari qui lui travaillait en carrosserie
chez les gaullistes comment est inactif
dans le mouvement on l'y voit moins
évidemment et puis ils font aussi partie
pour beaucoup de la majorité silencieuse
ils ont une manifestation le 1er juin
qui est passée un peu inaperçue
évidemment on retrouve des choses c'est
extraordinaire avec dédé des tracts qui
ont été voilà par avion qui ont été
jetés par avion au dessus de la
population des du bouche à oreille et il
est passé un peu plus inaperçu mais il y
avait là il y avait beaucoup il y avait
bien fait beaucoup de monde
vous avez manifesté à bella j'étais je
n'avais pas la jambe de bloquer comme
aujourd'hui donc geab un set j'ai fait
deux défilés dans ma vie pour vous
parler aux manifestations par les défis
des défilés pour apporter mon soutien au
général de gaulle qui est donc le
premier jean le 1er juin et puis
beaucoup de nombreuses années plus tard
ou là j'étais beaucoup plus engagé
politiquement ma fille était beaucoup
plus grande donc je pouvais pour aller
défendre l'école libre à paris voilà
c'est les deux défilés 4,4 du coût voilà
84e vis élimé en mélasse en 1968 ce
défilé du 1er juin
ça a été un bonheur intense de se
retrouver tous ensemble enfin on était
et pour défendre notre d'autres
président de la république jean cadets
vous nous avez dit ce fut un immense
succès midi mais 68 notamment sur le
plan des ati sociaux vous les avez cité
tout à l'heure c'est des bouchons parce
que finalement soit le les accords de
grenelle ce qu'on appelait encore renaît
doucement sur ce point là je voudrais
quand même repréciser cas jamais eu
d'accord à grenelle
aucune organisation syndicale n'a signé
ce qui a été un constat qu'on s'a de
fans discussions le 27 mai et c'est sur
cette base que peugeot a voulu que le
travail reprenne
on a considéré des grévistes également
que ce qui était proposé dans le cas de
grenay n'était pas suffisant c'est 30 %
d'augmentation du smic ça va ça suffit
on était bien entendu au dessus du smic
à sochaux et heureusement la plus grosse
entreprise industrielle devait avoir un
salaire supérieur au smic mais les os
quand même obtenu 14 % d'augmentation de
salaire avec aussi un point qu'a été
conséquent c'est la reconnaissance de la
sélection syndicat d'entreprise
parce qu'avant on écoute et très peu les
syndicats l'avaient d'exister au sein
des entreprises tel n'existe pas mais ce
que ya pas une immense désillusion quand
l'assemblée nationale est dissoute et
que les élections lui quelques jours
plus tard et là c'est un raz-de-marée
gaulliste railhawks allemands le bnd
belliard une tradition
différente de la france en 36 et le
front populaire qui l'emporté dans le
pays de montbéliard c'est des élus de
droite qui l'emportent dont un membre de
la famille peugeot no et moi en 68 c'est
pareil c'est plutôt une vague gaulliste
sur la france et dans le pays de
montbéliard
c'est andré boulloche kirill députés
dont 15 au bout mais au niveau national
jamais un parti n'avait eu une telle
majorité à l'assemblée
ok donc les gaullistes sortons renforcés
les grilles en tant que parti politique
peut-être me renforcer peut-être il n'en
demeure pas moins que général de gaulle
est oubliée démissionné en 1969 il a été
limité comme le rappelait pour la
socialiste de montbéliard qui a été élu
à prouver lien donc le courant gaulliste
à montbéliard n'a pas eu le succès comme
adam russo veut bien rappeler pourquoi
florian pasqualini mai 68 a des allures
de totem à droite comme à gauche
aujourd'hui
pour les uns c'est un immense progrès
pour les autres le début d'une voix de
la décadence oui oui si je dois cesser
difficiles expliqué c'est un mouvement
qu'il ya vraiment qu'à cristallisé si on
prend l'exemple du du pays de
montbéliard s'est cristallisée pourquoi
parce qu' une journée particulière en
l'occurrence le 11 juin sur la fin cette
journée du 11 juin qui est dramatique
que vous avez vécu aujourd'hui elle est
dans les mémoires comme un 11 septembre
2001 ou 1 12 juillet 98 tous les gens se
souviennent qu'ils étaient à ce moment
là pour la fin de la coupe du monde au
lit ou les tours je mélangerai senteurs
dans le pays de montbéliard le 11 juin
68 tous les gens qui l'ont vécue se
souviennent où il était ce qu'ils ont
vécu est quelque chose de très très fort
et si en dehors des considérations
nationales des des camps de droite ou de
gauche
je pense que le que l'on joint vraiment
marqué une rupture en tout cas dans le
pays de montbéliard
certains disent que c'est la fin du
paternalisme peugeot à partir de là on a
commencé à voir une opposition voilà
vraiment une lutte assez forte entre la
direction et syndicats qui existait déjà
mais qui s'est encore intensifiée
derrière et dormait 68 notamment au
début des
des mots des mobilisations étudiantes
qui à la remise en cause de l'autorité
est donc là on y revient avec le le
poids de la famille peugeot dans le pays
de montbéliard
mais la famille peugeot est qu'elle soit
vraiment aussi reconnaissante qu'elle
est implanté il y à plus de 100 ans
lusine dans notre région ça a quand même
permis de celui qui voulait travailler
ils pouvaient se faire une situation et
enfin ça a été là c'est la richesse de
notre pays c'est leur fait son renom et
tous et c'est extraordinaire je fais
partie de l' aventure peugeot
j'en suis mais honoré et fier les
populations très jeune en 68 aussi il
légalise étudiants et les ouvriers ou
les ouvriers sont une moyenne d'âge qui
est très très jeunes dans la vingtaine
d'années donc c'est voilà sa marque et
aussi avec ce régime
ce choix cette époque comptait 26 bill
700 salariés dans un nombre d'immigrés
également important et 170 n'avait pas
eu ces chiffres là il y avait déjà
beaucoup d'immigrés à ce jeu là qu'il
n'y en avait pas mais 60 1979 mais je
peux jours a toujours eu une politique
très dure vis-à-vis des salariés au
niveau social il n'y a qu'à regarder
deux noms de grève qui ont émaillé
l'histoire de ce show il se fait pas une
année sans tiers un conflit ou ou
locales ou plus ou plus importants et au
delà de l'aspect social et de ce qui se
passait dans les entreprises on a
l'habitude de dire que mai 68 a aussi
bouleversé
libéré en quelque sorte la société
française notamment sur la place des
femmes
jean cadets ça vous le mesurer vous le
confirmer par an 68 y avait peu
d'emplois féminins à le travail rennes
était très difficile aux personnels
féminins se limiter à l'atelier complet
de garnitures là où les femmes faisaient
les sièges donc là il y avait un
personnel faible important est ce
personnel féminin étaient également
engagés dans le conflit nous avions des
délégués féminin mais l'industrie
automobile à cette époque avait peu de
personnel féminin quelques exceptions si
on prend lusine les pays à
sainte-suzanne par exemple où je crois
que c'est 90 % de femmes et qui est un
mouvement aussi assez particulier avec
des revendications qui touche peut-être
un peu plus les femmes où on a des
cadres supérieurs et des techniciens qui
sont des hommes et les ouvriers
spécialisés les ouvrières étaient des
femmes du coup et elles ont un mouvement
aussi à l'époque c'était surtout des
ouvriers qui travaillaient sur les
chaînes guetter le personnel 28 ans
monique rousseau sur la place des femmes
est le
ce qui il ya un avant et un après 68
déjà un avant et un après de gaulle
puisque c'est le général de gaulle qui
nous a donné le droit de voûte c'est
déjà quelque chose d'important mais je
pense que même aujourd'hui il y a encore
à faire pour qu'on reconnaisse non pas
une parité
parce que je trouve que c'est plutôt
humiliée en qu'autre chose
je ne veux pas qu'on m'octroie quelque
chose parce que je suis une femme parce
que je suis capable
c'est je pense que sur le fait qu' il ya
encore vous mais il y avait encore il ya
encore des progrès à faire j'ai même la
messe que mai 68 a fait progresser les
choses selon vous malgré tout ce que
vous reprochez à ce mouvement
je ne lui reproche d'ailleurs je fais
pas que des reproches à des gens
peut-être qu'ils ont même sûrement
qu'ils avaient des situations très
difficiles et qui ont cru que c'était
par un conflit et en se heurtant les uns
les autres il fera avancer l'heure leur
situation
moi je sais pas comme ça que je vois les
choses mais c'est plutôt le
rassemblement du peuple français que de
voir les gens soeur et les uns les
autres mais je pense que le début de
l'accession des femmes à une égalité
date même d'avant 1968 puisque je crois
me souvenir de cette en 1965 qu'on a eu
le droit nous les femmes d'avoir un
compte chèques sans avoir l'autorisation
du mari ce qui nous amusent est bien à
la maison parce que c'était moi qui plie
compte depuis depuis un certain nombre
depuis notre mariage donc ya jamais eu 2
à sochaux ça je crois qu'il faut le dire
l'usiné était occupée ya jamais eu de
tentative de reprise de l'usiné par
quiconque
les salariés étaient étaient chez eux
d'où leur donnions des informations sur
le déroulement du conflit
peugeot n'a commencé à accepter de
négocier que le 31 mai à dire qu'il a
attendu plus de dix jours avant que nous
puissions des projets vraiment nos
revendications et c'est seulement pas
faire du 31 mai que les choses ont pu
avancer ya mariage
nous envoyer une question sur internet
là depuis le début de la semaine en
ligne sur notre la page de notre
émission et qui nous dit malheureusement
les français ne sont plus les mêmes et
c'est dommage
en l'occurrence est ce qu'un nouveau mai
68 vous paraît possible jean cadets vous
qui militait toujours jeu mais il est
toujours chez les retraités et là on est
on a beaucoup à faire avec par exemple
l'augmentation de la csg pour les
retraités mais la convergence
on va finir par vous mettre d'accord et
à faire sur cet aspect là on a plus dans
le même contexte
en 1968 la population salariée était
essentiellement en contrats cdd contrat
à durée indéterminée le problème du
chômage ne se faisait pas on allait au
contraire une augmentation de l'emploi
et si les férias l'emploi les
intérimaires n'existait pas non plus à
sochaux
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
le chômage est une préoccupation des
parents pour leurs enfants ou à ses
chaussures les 5000 salariés de
production plus de la moitié sont des
intérimaires ou en cdd
ce qui fait que les difficile
d'envisager un conflit comme celui de 68
nous sommes dans une situation
totalement différente il n'empêche que
les revendications demeurent et qu'il
faut toujours elle vient faire valoir
des droits qui aujourd'hui sont remises
en cause
florian pasqualini la capacité notamment
des syndicats a mobilisé tout autre
aujourd'hui oui montre une société plus
individualiste ça c'est indéniable
d'ailleurs que c'est en partie la faute
de mai 68
l'individualisme ça a changé
complètement le complètement l'avis de
la france je dirais pas que des français
il y a un avant et un après qui est et
plus on avance avec ce qu'on vit
actuellement
je trouve qu'il ya un individualisme qui
ce qui est ou voulue ou subie mais qui
déshumanise un peu oui c'est pas faux
l'individu allait si vous voulez peugeot
l'a développée il y avait un esprit de
solidarité et collectifs sur les chaînes
qui était très important
peugeot a tiré les enseignements de
cette grève elle a voulu briser ce
collectif il instituait ce qu'on
appelait le 10 po le dossier individuel
du personnel ouvrier qui consistaient en
des entretiens individuels ou les
salariés étaient dotées et dans la note
il y en avait une qui était le e qui
était le comportement vis-à-vis de
l'entreprise c'est à dire que peugeot
prenait en compte l'appartenance
syndicale politique philosophique pour
arrêter ça sa politique sociale
on a réussi à faire supprimer ce critère
par rapport à à l'esprit d'appartenance
à l'entreprise si peu jour bon et celui
et qui fournit le travail il nous non
pas moins que ce sont quand même les
salariés qui permet à peugeot de
s'enrichir
oui mais heureusement que peugeot peut
s'enrichir pour qu'on continue de
pouvoir embaucher
et puis que son temps après eh bien nous
sommes encore le bastion qui est l'ajout
embauches en mai la hausse ces derniers
mois ci plutôt qu'en 1970 aujourd'hui
nos flux le jeu vous dire une chose
monsieur moi j'ai été élevé dans une
famille où m'apprit que si je voulais y
arriver dans la vie il fallait que je
donne
il fallait que je travaille que ça
n'allait pas tombé tout rôti et jean je
suis extrêmement reconnaissante à
peugeot d'avoir pu me faire une
situation ce qui était pas d'ailleurs
tout évident à l'époque où j'étais vous
pensez que mai 68 par exemple a remis en
cause
le rapport des français au travail se
sait pas si on peut dire le rapport des
français au travail mais mai 68 je
trouve à développer qui existe est
peut-être inconsciemment peut-être mais
un certain égoïsme et puis une certaine
jalousie moi j'ai jamais jalouser la
famille peugeot
j'avais assez à m'occuper de la mienne
et puis que nous nous en sortions et on
avait appris que pour m'en sortir il
fallait que je travaille mais je les
fais avec
avec beaucoup de coeur moi je me sentais
comment je peux vous dire ça va
peut-être par et de grandiloquence que
je vais dire mais c'est ce que je
ressens une appartenance à cette usine
elle faisait un peu partie de ma vie
c'était et vient de lancer l'émission en
disant que vous en étiez fier donc voilà
un dernier mot florent florian pardon
pasqualini sur les évolutions sociétales
de l'après-68 l'a souvent pointé du
doigt pour la remise en cause de la
valeur travail ou de l'autorité quelles
conséquences à ussat exactement pour
sochaux monsieur cailleux pourrait
presque le dire mieux que moi mais si
pour la société de manière globale on
l'a dit tout à l'heure mais l'individu
rice ont été développés c'est à dire
qu'il n'y avait plus de récompenses à
militer parfois pour les copains dont
chacun un peu vu à midi à sa porte et
c'est un peu cassée syndicats yeux
l'apparition des syndicats jaunes par la
suite à peugeot sochaux qui a qui a
permis aussi papa qu'à sochaux
d'ailleurs une hanche comme souvenir à
saint-etienne et ses puits puis ailleurs
en france qui a qui a cassé un peu le
mouvement syndical mourier on a perdu de
cette solidarité aujourd'hui c'est un
fait voilà si on bat si ce sera leur
permettre non tout va vite c'est la fin
de cette émission c'est fini je suis
obligé de vous couper vers la brousse
aux honoraires invitera merci à tous
d'avoir suivi ce débat dans un instant
juste après le flash d'information
dimanche en politique continue avec
francis letellier qui reçoit le
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
la cohésion des territoires julien de
normandie bon dimanche à tous